a final moment of the uk's 20-year
military mission in afghanistan only
made public now
two weeks after the event the secrecy
apparently required because of security
concerns
instead of marching out victorious the
uk and other nato forces
have quietly departed as the taliban
gains ground
and fears of a civil war grow boris
johnson insisted the intervention
had made the uk safer from a terrorist
threat
once rooted in afghanistan no one should
doubt the gains
of the last 20 years but nor can we
shrink
from the hard reality of the situation
today
the international military presence in
afghanistan was never
intended to be permanent the timeline
for leaving was set by this man who said
his troops will be out by the end of
august
the united states did what we want to do
in afghanistan
to get the terrorists to attack us on 9
11
and deliver justice to osama bin laden
we're ending
america's longest war
but we'll always always honor the
bravery of the american patriots who
served it
he said taliban forces are at their
strongest since the invasion
here sky news was taken to what had been
an afghan army base in central wadack
province
now occupied by the taliban though
president biden said he didn't think a
complete taliban takeover was inevitable
more than 150 000 british forces served
in the u.s led war in afghanistan since
2001.
457 died while more than 2
400 american personnel perished as well
as almost
70 000 afghan security force members
this airbase north of kabul was once the
hub of the u.s military presence
now a husk handed back to the afghans
the intervention did improve the
standard of living for many
and deprived al qaeda of a haven to plot
acts of terror
that can that legacy endure with the
foreign firepower gone
clearly we've failed in our attempts to
stabilize afghanistan
and set it up for the future and so for
all those
my friends and people from here and all
over the world that have attempted
um and sacrificed an awful lot lives in
many cases
uh to deliver that outcome it's going to
be very hard for them to feel that it's
worth it
but the story of afghanistan isn't over
yet for this chapter though
journalists weren't allowed to attend
the uk's farewell ceremonies
or speak to troops on the ground afghans
now standing alone
even as britain says it's not turning
away
haynes sky news